[Music]
hey welcome to my first anime review and
today I'll be reviewing bleach bleach is
one of those animes that is really
popular you can't really tell why after
the first few episodes but once it gets
going it'll hope you really win and drag
you for one thrilling rides the plot
revolves around each go Kurosaki or
kudos lucky or however the [ __ ] you
pronounce it a normal 15 year old boy he
Percy ghosts but one day he meets the
Soul Reaper named Rukia accidentally
steals her powers and gets the job of a
Soul Reaper fighting evil spirits main
hollows now copy and paste the word
generic until you have enough worth it
for the scripts and you've just about
got synopsis of the first 15 episodes of
bleach see for me the plot doesn't kick
in until about episode 17 when they go
to Soul Society so if you have a short
attention span this really is not the
show for you but those of you with more
patience and can stomach the slow pace
and generic spoonfuls are the first 15
episodes of bleach let's talk about the
characters each go is your typical main
character who flies but all the things
again it seems have an influence 5 power
coming out of this ask whenever there's
a slight into trouble
then there's Rika who despite her looks
is actually about 500 years old and has
a weird bunny fetish and Chad who's in
the same years Ichigo but has the body
of a 25 year old and the voice of a 30
year old probably because he's been held
back 10 years re he may the tits II
clumsy character whose brain is stored
notice and she just about everything
else is stored in her tips with that
matter now Ishida the geeky type
character I suppose who tries to act
tough to look cool in front of always
Quincy friends but fails because they're
all dead and finally Renji there are
short fuse hot-headed character who
cares more about the size of his sword
than the size of his [ __ ] well I could
go on to describe where the other
characters in Bleach but the karlsen's
anime so large it could probably rival
the entire population of Sweden let's
see for the captains alone its soul
society there's captain long counter
captain [ __ ] ninja captain free show
captain complete hypocrite captain
[ __ ] captain Clark Kent captain
better the new captain grumpy pants
captain mom captain grab-ass crap and
senile captain bucket head own Kenpachi
let's not forget all the lieutenant
seated officers arrancars visoreds
ex soul reapers high school kids
bouncers and again an idea the sheer
amount of characters in this series see
this anime just has the tactile throwing
a bundle of cogsa and expects you to
memorize and keep up with them all now I
don't know about you but I had trouble
memorizing all the character's name let
alone their past histories the previous
scores their relation to other
characters their sword names their
favorite food and then red thugs or
because I missed that little bit of
dialogue that one episodes it seems that
the author didn't know whose target
audience was so instead he just opted
into throwing
every anime stereotype and I hope that
we would relate to one of them then when
he realized that he can possibly develop
them all he just tried to solve the
grumbo introduced more characters having
said that you'll find at least one
character you like since there are so
many to choose from it's near impossible
to not find one character who you can
relate to let's talk about the action in
Bleach the action is pretty good but
nothing we haven't seen before though it
does add a dash of stylishness which
does set it above other action animes
see they have this thing in Bleach where
each source is aimbot so has its own
special ability and name kind of like
Pokemon except they don't have to train
them or raise them it's not gay the
direction of the anime is going now it
seems that it's gone sick with the case
of Dragon Ball Z fever with endless
supply of power-ups coming out of
Aaron's arses and overly long training
episodes despite that I did thoroughly
enjoy Lee's MMA and still considered the
second dog one of the best shown in arcs
out there overall I give this anime a 7
out of 10